now we have our next keynote speaker
amongst us Dr nidhi khurana and uh and a
close colleague and uh I'm a head for
academic coordinator at Papa Universe
Academy so Dr khurana is currently the
head for uh Academy coordinator with
Faba Academy which is aimed at imparting
industry relevant skills to the life
science students so besides being a
molecular biologist by training she is
also a life science mentor and has
mentored over 200 more plus students
till now for career building in the life
science sector so uh with that I would
like to invite Dr khurana uh hello nidhi
uh I'm sure you guys are having a great
day and uh congratulations first of all
for this event and thank you so much for
introducing me to the audience
um okay so shall we get started
yes
great
um before I get started everybody
um I would love to know my audience so
and I would also appreciate if we can be
as interactive as possible so let me
start by asking all of you your uh you
know the current status are like your
educational qualification uh your stream
it would be nice to know your background
like in terms of where you come from as
in um educational qualification you know
your MSC PhD uh please type in the chat
box I would love to see some answers
because you know my talk is about
um finding that missing link between
Academia and Industry
people are talking about uh that the Gap
in Academia and Industry so what is that
Gap and what should we do as
professionals and as students you know
to fill that Gap to make a bright future
for ourselves so do we have an
interactive audience here my first
question uh let me know PhD wow thank
you Jodi for answering uh I'm expecting
a few more answers everybody
are you BSE Masters okay MSC biomatic
students Bachelors of Pharmacy very nice
thank you Tiffany Rupa Divya
great well by technology PhD MSC biodec
PSC
great PhD beginning uh
glad to know to receive MSC genomics and
precision medicine okay that's an
interesting mix of audience that you
have uh you know ranging from
undergraduates still phds and um
researcher okay so I will now share my
screen and you can keep answering the
chat box
um let me share
okay
can you all see my screen
give me a thumbs up
great
all right everybody
so
the you know that Gap that I talked
about between Academia and Industry it
is hurting the entire ecosystem the
entire uh ecosystem of Life Sciences
industry why because on one end the
companies complain that you know they
cannot hire fresh graduates or you know
inexperienced people because they do not
they're not adequately skilled
and on the other hand the complaint by
the students from the students is that
you know companies do not hire them and
so there's a misconception around number
of job opportunities or uh you know the
training the number of uh training
courses that can enhance their skills so
there is some kind of a missing uh link
there so my talk is going to focus on
what are the expectations of the
industry and what is Academia based on
my observations what is Academia
currently doing okay to help the
students make that transition
but before I delve into all of this
let me start by uh you know a common
expectation from uh that we have from
ourselves when we enter into college you
know that first day of college after
um after our school and what do you have
in mind when you join your college you
know the expected uh professional path
by the students look something like this
you know you ought to complete your
graduation or post graduation uh and
then you apply for jobs
uh you are expected you expect yourself
to get a job and then you perform well
you get promoted and then you know live
the life you desire so tell me you're at
least I had this uh expectation when I
joined the college I would love to know
from you after your BSC MSA PhD whatever
course you're doing what is your
professional expectation from you does
it align with what is what you're
looking at the screen right now yes or
no give me a thumbs up
do you expect to get a job from whatever
you're learning in your Institution
isn't that the sole purpose to find a
career for yourself
yes or no guys
okay
great
so exactly most of you are saying yes
that is the expectation you know but
do you think that this expectation is
being fulfilled just
in that manner that you are thinking
about it
so the reality is
the student completes graduation of post
graduation degree program
then they apply for jobs and then what
do you see you know struggle to get
hired
maybe you know most of you may have also
experienced it if you actually uh you
know tried applying for jobs you do not
hear from organizations for interviews
you send out your CVS to hundreds of
jobs but you know you know you do not
get back with any reply
you're told that you do not have the
required skill sets to work in the Life
Sciences industry
and maybe if you get an interview you
you turn down because again as a as a
fresher you're told that you do not have
relevant experience
you know
who how many of you actually relate to
either of the scenario here
Andy here says no jobs even after
Masters in life sciences
so you know I I do not want to comment
on that right now because there are jobs
Andy I can assure you that but it's just
the approach and because nobody's
preparing us to approach for those jobs
so that is why we are not taking the
right steps at the right time to really
benefit from the opportunity
so here the reality that you know that I
have shown you on the slide it resonates
with most of you
and this is what my observation after
talking to you know 500 plus students in
groups on personal basis
most of you come up with this scenario
so do you see a problem here with our
expectation from academic institutions
and basically the outcome of the entire
scenario
we expect our institutions our colleges
our universities to prepare us to build
a career in life sciences but somewhere
something is missing because after we
complete our education from that college
or university we actually end up
struggling to get a job
right
so what is that Missing Link what does
the industry tell most of the time to
the candidates who approach them for a
job that you do not have the adequate
skill sets and I'm sure and after
talking to a lot of students out there
life sciences students our academic
institutions do not even you know uh lay
enough emphasis on the term skill sets
you know enough so most of you or you
know if I have an intelligent audience
here good because most of the students
who I have talked about they are not
even aware of the term skill sets the
term skill sets confuse them so let me
just you know uh give a brief insight
into what a skill set is it is actually
the knowledge the ability or experience
needed to perform a job it could be any
job guys it could be r d it could be
management it could be uh you know
um accounting So based on the skill sets
that you have worked on and you know
you're working on to hone them with your
everyday practice or your experience or
your exposure you develop these skill
sets which you can use for the for your
job later in the future okay
so
in terms of skill sets also people talk
about two kinds of skill sets one is
soft skills it's basically nothing but
your personality on the whole how you
react personally to your surrounding in
various aspects but this another
um so with academic institutions do
contribute towards improving your soft
skills uh but most of the work should be
done by you
when it comes to hard skills these
skills are actually quantifiable and
teachable and they include the specific
technical knowledge and abilities
required for a job
so they are technique oriented and it is
the hard skills that the academic
institutions or we expect uh the uh the
institutions to prepare us when we you
know go for college go for a course to
prepare us in terms of hard skills so
that when we approach for a job at a
company we are not turned down because
of lack of adequate skill sets
so here now I would like to point out
various
um you know these are all my
observations and how what is Academia
focusing on instead of actually
preparing you for a career in life
sciences
so Academia
focuses on completing the syllabus and
giving good cgps to the students let me
know in the chat box if you agree to
these points or not I would love to see
your answers
see we have an educational curriculum to
follow okay and Academia restricts
itself to that curriculum
but what do I mean by giving good cgpas
actually most of us come from the
background where you know during our
school time with your top words if you
are among the top then we really you
know
um you know our parents take pride uh in
US and uh we really make uh everybody
proud our teachers our family and
everybody
so we have this mindset that when we
enter college that is the sole
requirement by a candidate to get a good
cgba most of us think when we entered
into our bachelor's program that having
good cgpa is what is going to give us a
very good job
but how many of you really know the
example of people who are doing great in
their career but have did not have the
good cgpu back in the day
it's actually not about the cgba cgp
absolutely matters because that is where
your basic understanding of the subject
is coming from
however
you need to implement the techniques the
subject knowledge that you're acquiring
okay and put it in Practical aspects so
what matters is exposure
so having cgpa is important but you need
to move Beyond cgpa to literally bill on
that career for yourself
second point
Academia actually teaches about
applications I'm not saying uh in our
colleges we've never had uh you know we
never knew the applications of any
technique that we were starting but the
Restriction here is the teach about
applications of a technique but only
theoretically
you know uh for example RDP recombinant
DNA technology how many of you have
answered the question you know where rdt
is used on a paper as a part of your
answer and listed the applications on
the answer and that's it you did it to
score good marks how many of you
literally delve into the detail of the
application of rdt in solving real life
problems which companies uh you know
with Solutions are
um you know they're favored by rdt
so it's only theoretically that the
focus is uh fixed on
the third aspect is actually all the
basic and advanced knowledge of the
topics are covered but you know how
these are implemented to find a solution
or create a product is not emphasized
upon let me know you know you are
allowed to uh give your views here with
respect to the points that I'm putting
up guys so when we study about any topic
during our College yes we need to study
about its Basics yes we study about its
Advanced but what we fail to study is
the implementation of the technology to
really find a solution or how using the
technology a product is created in real
life scenario
right so that is where the Gap is in
understanding the entire
um operations behind Life Sciences
industry
another
Academia actually thinks industrial
visits are enough to teach students
about how the work happens in an
industry
so let me know while I was you know uh
putting up this point uh this I mean I
was laughing to myself but actually
that's true in my MSC also I had an
industrial visit and I I'm sure your
universities also most of the places and
they arrange these industrial visits to
understand you know to give you a sense
of how industry works but is that what
is required what does it even do for
like five hours or six hour visit what
does it how does it help a student
but colleges do well
um and basically they should do
something more than that to really help
the students understand the entire
scenario of flight Sciences industry
another point they do not educate the
students about the concepts of skills
that's required in the industry as I've
emphasized upon it earlier that you know
the term skill sets how to build on them
how to really analyze the strengths and
weaknesses to develop those skills
that's for you so that you really enjoy
what you do going forward
it's completely lacking
and then the ironically very few
institutes try to place their students
after their graduation
but the entire process of those
placements that occur for life science
student is follow
it does not have any meaning and does
not help the students much in their
career building guys now that's the
truth you like it or not most of you how
many of you literally continue with the
job that you know that you're placed
after your college does that even align
with your strengths and weaknesses does
that give you a sense of uh you know
whether you are built for the job or not
whether you're going to enjoy it or not
nothing there's no preparation behind
that uh scenario so
Academia does a lot there are a lot of
points here but I think the way it
executes this thing needs to have more
meaning to it
let me know if you agree to me or not
here give me a thumbs up if we are
aligned on this uh um you know at this
magnitude so give me a yes or no if you
really connect to what I'm talking here
on the other hand guys I need you to
focus on what the industry wants okay
till now we actually saw what Academia
is providing Us in terms of preparing us
for career building and Life Sciences
but what is what is it that the industry
wants
so everything is based on the
applications of the techniques in the
industry
okay we have talked to many people from
far by itself we conduct many panel
discussions we are going to one-on-one
personal meetings with with the industry
leaders to understand the Gap you know
so everything in industry is based on
applications of the techniques
industry is actually product or solution
Centric okay it seeks individuals who
understand the basics and applications
of the techniques used in the company
when they say that you do not have the
adequate skill set what do they imply
so for example they're looking for
somebody who uh they're looking for
somebody who knows about the use of hplc
okay now if you're someone who's used
splc before you fit right into their
pocket but the thing is if you are not
very well acquainted with hplc if you do
not know how to handle the equipment if
you do not know uh you know how to work
with it how to generate data with it how
to interpret its data or troubleshoot
the experiments that are performed with
that experiment then
you know you cannot add value to that
job
and industries look when they go through
your resumes when they go through your
profiles what you're looking at they're
looking at various ways how you can add
value to them how you can help them grow
and that is where this lack of a skill
set is coming in
our educational curriculum is too much
focused on providing us basic and
subjective knowledge when it comes to
practical it's mostly restricted to
whatever we learn in the Laboratories
but that does not do justice to what is
required in real time at industry level
okay so industry seeks individuals who
know how to handle the equipment can
generate and interpret the data and most
importantly is able to troubleshoot
experiments
sometimes industry would employ somebody
who would not have a hands-on experience
of hplc so there is this another Factor
when you are interviewing for that
position or you are uh you're not
telling about yourself to that uh
recruiter potential recruiter it's more
about your attitude your uh you know if
you would not have had the hands-on
experience on hplc but you should know
what hplc is what is its principle what
is the uh you know uh the insights
behind generating data from it how does
it help their projects you know like why
do you use hplc so at least these are
the aspects you need to know and then as
a pressure having Hands-On or no having
Hands-On can be tackled at some level
okay so for that only you know there was
this one um
a statement in the chat box which said
that there are no uh not enough job
opportunities after msc's so there are
guys okay it's just that we need to
approach them in the right Manner and
Life Sciences students actually need to
put in a little bit more effort as
compared to the other streams
engineering I.T computer science
anything uh because they have been
established from a very long time ago in
this in this scenario and for Life
Sciences uh students mostly the paths
you know till now has been BSC MSC PhD
postdoc and then becoming a professor
right but now you see a lot of companies
you see a lot of Industry uh you know
organizations that are coming up with
projects with Healthcare projects with
life sciences by that Pharma you know
it's always been there and now it's time
to open up our minds also to explore
these opportunities but life science
students need an extra push an extra
nudge to really approach those
opportunities in this case
so now we know what industry wants from
us and how Academia is not able to uh
provide us that kind of training
here I have actually put up a snapshot
for you about the typical academic
syllabus that we have so this is a
general some of the general topics that
all of us find in our syllabus beat MSC
biotech microbiota biochemistry
and then below I actually have industry
skill requirements
so you see in our academic syllabus we
have these victims you know buying for
marriage genomics and proteomics
bioentrepreneurship uh nanobiotechnology
bioprocessing engineering and
fermentation technology
these are actually industry relevant
subjects or topics
the problem is how the Activia teaches
us about these subjects
for example genomics and procurement so
bioinformatics
if you really think Academia was doing
enough to really you know impart that
skill to us which was industry relevant
then an organization like omix Logix
okay which is doing great work in this
scenario would have had no meaning
but you know mixed logic you are
attending this webinar you are a part of
their courses you know what the teach
how they teach how nicely project
oriented they are you know so case
studies
are important you need to work on real
life problems to really understand how
bioinformatics or genomics is a
proteomics or nanobiotechnology is
helping you find a solution
that is what is needed okay when it
comes to Industry skill requirements I
want you to see the difference so
industry skill requirements are Advanced
technical Concepts in molecular biology
in Metro assays and people models
pre-clinical drug Discovery and
development bio biopharmaceutical
production and Analysis you know facets
of Industry r d focusing on product
development and correlation between
functions
industry focuses on physiology
pharmacology toxicology and Regulatory
studies you tell me which of these
topics are covered in the academic
syllabus in a way that we should be
prepared to get a job right after our
degree
like like legible guys negligible
so here is the gap when I say that skill
set is the missing link between Academia
and Industry what I mean is this
okay
going forward
what needs to change to really have a
positive effect on this entire scenario
what Academia can do at their level to
really help the students build their uh
career in life sciences industry
starting right at the bachelor's level
there should be mandatory industrial
internships and preferably for three
months why do you say this you know so
uh one day
um from Papa we were organizing this
workshop on drug Discovery and
development and you know
um basically the our partner from the US
he randomly said that you know in our
curriculum uh the the students start
taking internships from the very first
year of their bachelor's so they're you
know in the U.S ambassador is like four
years so by the time they complete four
years they have an exposure of working
in four different Industries at four
different roles
and so that is why when they graduate
they actually feel ready to perform in
the industry
okay you are no longer lost because
you've had prior four times experience
of reflecting what you like what you
don't like what are these various job
opportunities how I can perform best in
this particular role you know
uh you know having been connected to
people at four different places you have
built a community and network for
yourself so strong that after four years
after those four uh internships you are
actually connected to people who can
help you get the job that's what
networking is
and that's what Skilling looks like
another thing that the colleges can uh
you know uh Ponder upon is empowering
the culture of working on projects based
on real life problems to add to the
students experience and Foster
entrepreneurship right now you know
these colleges have these plate
replacement cells and Entrepreneurship
departments and sell
but the thing is some active a proactive
approach needs to be taken to empower a
culture where the students are uh you
know they are required to team up to
work on real life problems to find a
solution at their level there could be
many solutions to one problem everybody
and so when you do that you actually get
real-time hands-on experience and you
Foster that mindset of Entrepreneurship
the solution Centric mindset another
thing exposure to the pilot scale
manufacturing projects and quality
control studies for students should be
conducted by collaborating with startups
or Industries to impart industry
relevant skills
you know college also needs to educate
them about careers outside Academia and
the necessary skills that each of those
careers require
because it is also important to
understand that research and development
is not the only option after your
bachelor's Masters or PhD everybody you
do have different roles where you can
outperform by your skill sets by your uh
you know likings and disliking by
reflecting by building on your strengths
and considering your weaknesses you can
go for other careers other than research
and development it's not mandatory as a
master's student to really just go for
research after your you know after
getting the degree so College needs to
educate them about various career
opportunities and how to prepare for
them by telling them that this
particular job requires these Trends and
if you are a person who has those
strengths go for that job you know so at
the Last Thing released that the college
can do is encourage the students to
build their career based on the
strengths and weaknesses rather than
following the third just what I just
mentioned
so over here guys let me know in the
chat box that are you with me here or do
you have any contradictory comment or
your point of view or your perspective
about this so because I think that this
is where the Gap lies this is how the
academic institutions need to act upon
to really uh build uh you know that
mindset to really build experience to
really give the confidence to the
students for career building and life
sciences
going forward now this is a scenario
that that was a scenario that academic
uh you know institution need to uh do at
their level but that's I don't know how
far that is from uh practicing so what
you can do at your level guys so
considering what the industry wants from
you considering the limited amount of
work that the Academia can put in
preparing you for getting jobs it is
your responsibility to take proactive
steps in these areas that are shown here
so what you can do to make your
transition smoother from academic
industry go for internships everybody
you know go for internships
at least once a year
while you're doing that internship
reflect on your strengths or build your
experience around it okay you need to
reflect on your strengths if you're
liking it if you're disliking it or if
you know if you need to consider that on
an everyday uh basis would you be
enjoying this role that you are a part
of right now because having an
internship skill gives you a lot of
exposure that is required to really
build that fulfilling career going ahead
second is focus focus focus on
networking online and offline I cannot
say it enough and I don't know if you're
following me on LinkedIn most of my
posts they focus on this particular
Point networking as Life Sciences
students nobody uh talks about it nobody
encourages us for it and so whenever we
talk to uh people when whenever we talk
to the students always say I'm not a
conversationalist you do not need to be
a conversationalist to actually network
network is when you connect with people
when you deliver value when you take you
know help them and take their health and
build a community for yourself
so work on it when I say online and
offline I'm talking about platforms like
LinkedIn and offline I'm talking about
conferences symposiums your class your
seniors your professors
make full use of conferences and
symposiums talk to people you know you
should go prepared when you go for a
conference so that you know you you go
with the targeted approach
then you build connections reach out to
your alma mater reach out to your
professors you know the entire strategy
can really help you find that job for
yourself it can easily get you hired if
you start with this strategy at a very
at the right time it is not late for
anybody else okay but if you start at a
younger level then you actually have
ample amount of time to build around
these so the last is increase your
visibility talk to people let them know
you exist until you tell them you exist
how are they going to find out that you
know you are some person who is strong
at this and may be perfect for this job
so if you increase your visibility if
you talk to people around if you network
right if you approach people and build
connections there is no reason or there
is no scenario that you cannot get hide
so these are some things that you can do
at your level to really bridge the gap
and make your transitions cool from
Academia to Industry
so guys um I'll just take last two to
three minutes to
tell you how far Academy is helping in
this space
so to educate the students and support
the students as they explore and further
understand themselves in the career
options and to gain valuable experience
power Academy was launched in 2020 and
what we do is we conduct webinars which
are career oriented we uh conduct these
workshops which uh upskill the
participants uh in Industry relevant
skill sets which gives them better
career growth so just uh giving us just
about who is Faba Academy for so it has
a lot to offer to every kind of domain
of Life Sciences sector graduates and
postgraduates PhD postdocs and Industry
professionals faculty everybody uh so
our strengths are we have upskilled
actually 400 plus participants including
early career professionals our speakers
are you know for these workshops are
invited from India and abroad to give
you really uh wholesome uh you know
exposure about the advancements that are
happening in technology the career
opportunity that are coming up in this
field
and so these are some of the workshops
that we have conducted like drug
Discovery and development basis of
chromatography techniques
um Hands-On training on DNA
fingerprinting biosity biosecurity
Upstream internship Technologies of
biologics and biosimilar and we do
conduct workshops in collaboration with
Comics Logics also uh just like this we
did last year biomedical data science
and Drug Discovery and Drug Discovery
development this year so now we're
moving on to doing more Hands-On
Workshop because until uh you know 2021
it was more like virtual but when you
gain these extra skill sets which are
industry relevant you are actually
equipping yourself with those adequate
skill sets that the industry is looking
for so with this guys the these are some
of the webinars that we have conducted
um you know for example rnai
Technologies and current opportunities
this was about next Generation
sequencing and this was about science
communication you know rewrite it
Trends to become a science Communicator
we invite the experts from Indian abroad
their CEOs they are doing outperforming
uh themselves in their field so they
bring their own wisdom and experience to
teach you about these aspects
um this is about the uh one of the
upcoming webinars with Dr Gotham Das who
is the co-founder and managing partner
of my Biome Therapeutics and it is on
8th September I would love for you to
explore uh this opportunity and register
for this webinars or webinars are free
of cost and so uh you um be a part of it
and gain some value out of it so guys
with this thank you so much
um I would love to answer some questions
if you have and let me know if there is
any way that I can help you with thank
you very much